I'm a comedy writer.
All right guys, very funny stuff.
I also write for Broadway and movies.
Why is your face suddenly bigger than it was before?
Oh my god!
Are you allergic to seafood?
She doesn't have insurance...
...and she really shouldn't be leaving him by herself.
You daughter is going to be fine.
Why did you tell the doctor that I was your father?
I was a little loopy by then.
Who are they?
That's my family.
If they're your family, why do you have their names written down?
Charlie, you can't be alone anymore.
If you ever need my help, I'm here.
I'm writing something and I have to finish before my words run out.
I'll take care of them.
May I ask what your relationship is?
I don't know.
Do you live here?
I'm his friend.
But your dad needs you right now.
I mean, this young woman is full of surprises.
This is no time for jokes.
It's the perfect time for jokes.
You funny old man.
I want to have fun.
I want to laugh.
I want to not be scared...
...and I want to write the book...
...and I want to do all of that with you.
Hell yeah!